Okay, let's go to something a little lighter
today. Instead of voicemails. I have a beautiful
email for you today. I got a a an email from
someone who says that my pronunciation has
cured their depression. Chris wrote to me
and said, Hey David, your pronunciation of
Pete boot edge, edge and tool C Gabard cured
my depression. Thank you. You know, the funny
thing about boot edge edge is when Pete Buddha
judge at the beginning was not well known.
A lot of people didn't know how to pronounce
his last name and he came out and said it's
very easy. It's three words, boots, edge,
edge. And so I've just been pronouncing it
that way. Pete, boot edge edge. Even though
I'm not running it together the way a normal
person might do a, I'm glad that you like
it. I'm glad that you like uh, me referring
to the candidate as tool C and I'm a hope.
I don't know how serious this is, but to any
extent that I can help someone if they're
in a tough spot or a or feeling depressed,
uh, I am glad to be able to be a part of that.
Thanks Chris. Appreciate it. We've got a great
bonus show for you today. Elizabeth Warren
is proposing criminal penalties for spreading
voting disinformation online. We will also
have two border related stories. One serious,
the longest ever border smuggling tunnel has
been found stretching between [inaudible]
and San Diego, and a piece of the U S border
wall just fell over. It was windy. So the
border wall fell over onto the Mexican side.
Yeah. We'll talk about all of those stories
and more on the bonus show. Two ways to get
instant access to the bonus show. Number one,
become a member@joinpacman.com please sign
up folks. Please sign up. Uh, that's my, uh,
uh, Jeb Bush. Please clap a quote and you
can become a patron at the $5 or greater level
to also get instant access to the bonus show.
That's patrion.com/david TACNCO. I'll speak
to you then, or otherwise, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].